I feel like in honor of this incredible
anniversary you're going to announce the
Titanic reboot with Leo called I didn't
let you go Jack can this happen today
no but you can go and see Titanic one
re-release at a movie theater near you
is that any good
that was really good I was just hoping
for a reboot so you're saying we have a
chance
no but you can go and see the film again
okay okay fine all right listen this
really is the perfect date night movie I
mean I've seen it a million times why do
you think it is the perfect date night
movie for Valentine's Day
I
am nostalgic
I know so many people who went on their
first date with their now husband and
they have you know three children
together and Titanic was their first
date I you know it's that sort of
magical formula that you can sometimes
never put your finger on and also maybe
we don't want to put our finger on
exactly why it's that old classic it is
the ultimate love story in a way you
know that anything The Sounds the music
the scope of it the costumes you know
these two little young lovers running
around a sinking ship
there's something just glorious and
amazing about all of that and it's
wonderful that it's being released again
another whole young people are going to
go and watch it in a movie theater maybe
for the first time and that's it's
incredible to be part of something like
that absolutely and my question is do
you stay up late at night and ever
Ponder like should I have let Jack on
the door because I feel like he should
have come on the door and recently James
Cameron realized he did a scientific
test that said Jack could have come up
on the door
you know every time I see Jim he's like
can you believe they're still going on
about that bleep door
um and I'm like well of course they are
um yeah I think you probably could have
gotten on the door I mean you know it's
one of those things I have to be honest
I kind of like
you know I live with this I live with
this whole thing of like could he have
gotten on the door I'm 40 years old now
you know this is over half my life I've
been living with could jack have fitted
on the door or not
um I'd like to know actually what
happened to the door because I think
I've had to talk about it the most and
so in a way perhaps it should even be my
door but I don't even know where it is
we need to find that with that we need
to find out because if we could find
that out and then try and get me and Leo
on it I mean we're both probably a
little bit fatter so I think like if the
experiment may not go quite according to
where but we can try